tu es le seul et l'unique blue ça tombe
bien vu que je suis le dernier mile de
mon espèce est découverte très important
nous avons trouvé les traces de vie
taarab le sauvage en pleine jungle
amazonienne
alors on italie c'est là peut-être toute
une population nous devons aider linda y
tout lyon est trouvée nous commence à
nous l'oiseau domestique qui vient
d'apprendre à voler 21 ouvrir la loi de
la jungle
nous partons tous pour l'amazonie le 9
avril les a trouvés et tout vient tout
doucement papa incroyable je suis grand
père monsieur les enfants doucement avec
toi tu m'appelles monsieur par les
créateurs de l'âge de glace bienvenus
roberto bonjour aux jantes et je suis le
compagnon teubert là tu m'a jamais parlé
d'un roberto alors un vrai un ara bleu
ça ressemble à ça blue pearl à ce sont
des pastilles de menthe ça se mange pas
croyable mais gros nico on avait tous on
aurait pu devenir des légendes enfin bon
ok on est déjà dit dieu mais tu vois ce
que je veux dire
luis et la sphère
allez mon pote roberto je vous invite
dans mon lit ces trois fois rien gelée
bricoler avec ma force et mes muscles
vector et pour la première fois
gaby je vais me faire une joie de vous
gâcher la fête
ça ne marche que quand c'est moi qui le
fais rions 2 fait gaffe à toi barbare il
est accro q